we know school's out for the summer and
we're here at new eight news now are
trying to help kids and families find
things to do so all week long
we're highlighting local businesses and
camps that'll keep the little ones
learning and having fun and even showing
off their creative side today bianca
holmen taking us to a camp
for aspiring young performers hi bianca
hey good morning good morning everybody
at home do you have a future
thespian in your home are they tired of
waiting in the wings they're ready to
break out they're ready for their debut
on stage this is the camp for them and
to share more
about what's happening here i'm joined
by jessica galore who was a
cultural advisor here at the city of las
vegas and can tell us more about this
performing arts camp so i know there's
lots of kids they may be sleeping in but
their parents are up
tell us more about what you all are
offering well here at rainbow company
youth theater which is under the office
of cultural affairs
we have some wonderful opportunities
right now for students to come in and
learn about the fundamentals of theater
through our theater workshops
we have workshops for ages 8 to 16 this
summer
our first workshop is our youth acting
workshop for ages 8 to 11
where they'll learn the fun fundamentals
of theater voice body imagination while
they're learning collaborative play
as well as fostering their creativity
and our second workshop which is our
teen acting intensive
is a little bit of a deeper dive into
learning about acting and its techniques
and finding out how to create believable
characters on stage
and also you know again in the spirit of
collaboration and learning about
teamwork and leadership
yeah this is so important because for
the past year drama teachers music
teachers art teachers they've been doing
this virtually which is
it's pretty difficult so this is so
important that things are back in person
for these kids
absolutely i think every child and every
parent is looking for this kind of
opportunity so we feel really fortunate
to be able to
provide that for them here in the city
of las vegas along with many other many
other workshops and camps throughout
the entire city we can offer to them
this summer all right perfect so we
are going to bring up some more details
a little bit later on in the next half
hour because
if maybe you know acting and they're not
going to say to be or not to be
their thing maybe they want to move with
their body and express themselves with
their body so we got some details about
the dance camp that they have here also
offered here in the city of las vegas
back to you guys in the studio
thank you so much bianca so our summer
fun series is going to be continuing all
week
long tomorrow we're going to check out a
computer coding camp for kids so you
don't want to miss that one john
i'm looking forward to seeing you also
bianca do some shakespeare later on in
the program
i'm expecting some macbeth or something
along those lines we'll